à plaisir on l'a appris avec le dépôt
des listes officielles cinq candidats
sont engagés dans la campagne bonsoir
jean louis mais teulet bonsoir monsieur
canal et vous êtes la tête de liste de
rassemblement pour plaisir vous faites
partie des quatre candidats dans les
yvelines avoir été investi par le
rassemblement national la formation je
le précise est aussi présente dans
d'autres villes par le biais d'alliances
précisons qu'à plaisir une liste front
national avait récolté en 2014 9,25 %
des voix une liste conduite à l'époque
par le conseiller municipal d'opposition
aleksandar nikolic est pour vous
jean-louis mais teulet vous avez été
engagée au sein d'un conseil municipal
pendant dix ans en région parisienne
dans une autre ville de la région
parisienne
pourquoi vous engagez cette fois ci à
plaisir tout à fait donc j'ai été
autrefois effectivement conseil
municipal à l'opposition aujourd'hui
nous voulons servir plaisir
nous avons remarqué que dans la ville
malheureusement depuis huit ans ce
n'était plus du tout le même climat
qu'autrefois nous avions un ancien maire
joël regnault où on pouvait aller le
voir il n'était dans la ville on pouvait
discuter lui poser des questions on
avait des réponses plus ou moins
satisfaisante mais au moins on avait une
vie municipale sur plaisir aujourd'hui
on a du mal à rencontrer notre mère on
la voit que dans des réunions publiques
et lorsqu'il y à une réunion souvent on
nous impose
on va dire des projets dans une réunion
de concertation finalement on n'est pas
écoutés donc on est très insatisfaits de
l'ambiance et de la dérive que l'on a
depuis huit ans je gagnais qui a été élu
jusqu'en 2012 et joséphine coleman ce
berger lui a succédé à l'est d'ailleurs
un candidate à nouveau pour un prochain
scrutin est ce que la liste qui est que
vous présentez aux prises roi est ce
qu'elle est similaire à celle qu'elle
est présentée le front national en 2014
à les renouveler
aujourd'hui alors bien sûr il ya un
renouvellement puisqu'il ya des
personnes qui ont fait un chemin depuis
huit ans pour lui qui ont évolué qui ont
déménagé ou qui je ne sais pas ne
s'intéressent plus au contraire d'autres
personnes s'intéressent aux affaires
municipales
donc bien sûr c'est une liste qui a
évolué en huit années tout à fait
qu'avec de nouveaux visages alors un
triptyque pour votre programme sécurité
identité et proximité que l'on va
détailler dans
un instant sur le plan des projets alors
vous dénoncé un manque de concertation
finalement de la mère joséphine coleman
ce berger mais sur le plan des projets
quel regard vous portez sur ce qui a pu
être mené sur le dernier mandat
sur le dernier mandat
en fait moi j'ai des il ya plusieurs
projets sur lequel on n'avance pas ça
fait huit ans que j'alerte la mairie sur
certains projets et on n'a pas avancé
il ya des sujets qui bloque et puis il
ya des sujets qui avance je trouve que
nous avons à plaisir malheureusement bon
il ya une politique
effectivement de limiter les dépenses
qui est très bien mais sur certains
domaines c'est parfois trop juste il
donc il faudrait vraiment une écoute des
habitants et offrir une qualité de vie
ce que nous n'avons pas forcément ou pas
suffisamment sur notre ville alors si on
détaille votre programme sur le volet
identité la mesure principale c'est
préserver le cadre de vie à plaisir
alors vous proposait notamment de
dynamiser le centre-ville limiter la
bétonisation ça fait partie de vos
propositions de quelle manière vous
comptez y parvenir alors dynamiser le
centre ville c'est quelque chose qui
faisait déjà
enfin qui était déjà criant des dès
l'arrivée de madame le maire en 2012
donc à rien n'a été fait en huit années
alors il ya une rénovation qui a été
enclenché du centre ville oui il ya des
effets d'annoncé effectivement nous
sommes sûr plaisir sur une politique
d'annonce une politique de communication
et finalement nous ne sommes pas écoutés
nous n'arrivons pas à nous faire
entendre par exemple nous avons des
problèmes sur le stationnement à la
guerre plaisir grignon
ça fait plusieurs années que j'en parle
que j'ai demandé un parking sur cette
gare et c'est un projet qui n'a pas
avancé
en huit ans il a fait partie de vos
propositions ça le parminou tout à fait
effectivement c'est une une question
très importante pour nous puisque de
nombreux à la fois des plaisirs wacom
des gens extérieurs ne parviennent pas à
se garer pour prendre le train alors
qu'on parle aujourd'hui d'écologie de
prendre les moyens alternatifs de
transport
ben en fait il n'ya pas une offre ideo
parking satisfaisante sur la gare de
plaisir grignon
alors soit volet sécurité vous voulez
augmenter les moyens de la police
municipale développer la vidéoprotection
aussi à lutter davantage contre la
délinquance notamment au quartier du val
ibo qui a été touchées par des
phénomènes de violence des affrontements
notamment avec la police comment vous
comptez
l'ugtt est justement contre contre cette
délinquance oui il ya la violence
et puis il ya aussi les stupéfiants il
ya des trafics de drogue il ya beaucoup
de choses qui ne vont pas alors c'est
vrai qu'on a on rénove 7 ce quartier où
cet éco quartier
mais on oublie finalement le fond une
politique de fond et non pas une
politique d'apparence une politique de
fond c'est déjà dire dans ce quartier il
ya de la violence
si on met plus de 60 millions d'euros
dans ce quartier on peut quand même
consacré une partie de cette somme à la
sécurité si si vous vous promenez dans
plaisir je pense que vous n'aimeriez pas
être agressés ou être en danger dans
notre ville donc je pense que les
priorités sont pas toujours bien défini
actuellement et qu'il faut offrir aux
plaisirs oies et au plaisir oise une
sécurité pouvoir se promener et être
heureux dans notre ville et le dernier
axe et la proximité alors vous souhaitez
notamment rapprocher les quartiers il
est une proposition par exemple de créer
des navettes internet interquartiers par
mois ça ce sont des pistes
oui pour rapprocher davantage les les
plaisirs roi ce n'est pas une piste
c'est une certitude
on voit dans de nombreuses villes des
navettes interquartiers et c'est très
utile pour les habitants les personnes
âgées qui ne peuvent pas conduire ou se
déplacer aimerait ses navettes
l'interquartiers ainsi que les personnes
avec handicap
peut-être aussi des enfants et il faut
savoir qu'il ya une modification du
réseau de bus qui a mécontenté la
population et malgré tout on a une
nouveaux dispositifs de réseau de bus
qui ne qui n'est pas fonctionnel qui
n'ôte qui ne convient pas beaucoup de
personnes et le projet est passé malgré
des concerts des fausses concertation
avec les habitants
il y avait beaucoup de personnes
remontés contre ce projet et malgré tout
il est passé un dernier mot sur la
question de la santé plaisir et est
classé en zone d'action complémentaires
on sait que c'est un problème qui va se
poser à plaisir et que de nombreux
médecins qui partent à la retraite et
qui seront non remplacés vous souhaitez
vous par exemple la création d'une
maison médicale
c'est ça à plaisir oui oui tout à fait
monsieur canal est donc une maison
médicale c'est indispensable
et je ne comprends pas pourquoi l'équipe
municipale n'a pas prévu n'a pas géré
cela depuis huit ans on savait que les
médecins était haché qui deviendrait
beaucoup départ en retraite
voilà on a vu venir on a laissé faire et
il s'est rien passé je ne comprends pas
et après on nous sert de la
communication de la publicité pour nous
dire que la ville est très active
or là on voit un grand une grande
carence un grand défaut de l'équipe
municipale
donc nous voulons vraiment changer les
choses à plaisir
en conclusion on pourrait dire que nous
ce qu'on veut c'est pas une politique
spectacle pas une politique de
communication
on veut vraiment répondre aux attentes
des habitants et leur offrir une qualité
de vie et on retrouve votre agenda de
campagne comme celui des autres
candidats sur le site internet de tv 78
points comme merci jean louis met l'aide
est revenu en plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes la tête de liste de
rassemblement pour plaisir une liste
investie par le rassemblement national
et sont également en lice pour le poste
de maire à plaisir l'édile sortant de
joséphine coleman ce berger l'ancien
adjoint aux finances patrick l'inter et
les conseillers municipaux d'opposition
annie joël prix ou admis ainsi que jamel
niati